make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are back with
the conclusion of
marvel zombies resurrection right this
wraps up the whole thing and what we do
here is we kind of start off
a little bit ago and essentially what's
left of the superhero community right
even just super hero and super villain
community
right so you've got miles morales you've
got bucky barnes you got doctor strange
you've got electro
right spider-man villain well-known
spider-man villain you've got these
different characters who are here
and seemingly out of nowhere they're met
by the arrival of
spider-man who of course has valeria
richards and franklin richards in tow so
this is during the initial
outbreak here now the truth is that this
is kind of cool and this kind of makes
sense
this is where marvel zombies
resurrection could either succeed
incredibly well or fail disastrously
so far the story is not too bad i mean
it definitely needs some work and
there's definitely some expansion that i
think needs to be done in order to make
it make more sense
but there's a lot of great stories that
could be told here right like everything
that was going on
during the initial outbreak and that's
why i say i think that marvel zombies
started happening the way that it did as
a direct response to deceased right that
we got the marvel zombies returned one
shot and then we got nothing for like a
year
and then we get you know marvel zombies
number one long after deceased has
already kind of
done its thing right and basically told
his main story and so with peter parker
and them arriving he basically begs
anybody to save franklin richards and
nobody can
right not even doctor strange right he's
like there's nothing i can do here i
can't say franklin but warlock steps up
and says i can save him
but it won't necessarily be the way that
you think and so again picking back up
in the modern day right now we have
peter and the rest of the heroes who
went to the galactus hive right where
galactus basically crash landed on earth
as kind of the first of the infected so
to speak
carrying all the other infected heroes
and then bringing them here
and so with with you know peter
encountering mary jane of course she's
kind of beseeching him telling him hey
you know join us that kind of a thing
and then basically in the middle of
nowhere you know when
when uh susan goes to bite franklin then
suddenly
phalanx starts emerging out of franklin
richards and the whole shield and
everything of susan storm lets down and
that's what we end up finding out that
the way that franklin lived is that this
is not actually franklin richards right
it is but it's not truly like the like
the true franklin the true franklin
richards has long since been dead right
he died at the very beginning of the
whole thing because he was bitten
what ended up happening is that warlock
used his phalanx ability right so
basically this kind of like
techno-organic virus kind of ability to
basically create a new franklin
richard's body and then the
consciousness of franklin was moved by
doctor strange from his old body
into his new body and so that's why he
doesn't recollect anything that happened
he doesn't recall being bitten or any of
that stuff because he is kind of a
wholly new created character
the thing about this is that he's not
fully human the other part of this is
that valeria once she starts to kind of
realize the way things truly are that
her family really can't be saved she
does what she has to do and she
basically starts killing them right she
starts killing off
ben grimm and and johnny and and reed
and susan and all them she basically
starts killing them all you know it's
you know and
and sucks right because she has to
annihilate her family the other part of
that
is that chewie the cat who of course can
swallow huge amounts of stuff
ends up spitting back up a bunch of the
robots that it had previously swallowed
when they were in
the machine city and so it's kind of uh
you know ad hoc reinforcements right
and things are happening super fast here
and of course that basically leads to
peter accepting the fact that mary jane
is not actually his girl anymore iliana
rasputin tries to go toe-to-toe with
blade and of course you know she kind of
gets the upper hand on him to a degree
of course doesn't necessarily kill him
but when she goes in for the killing
blow wolverine finally re-emerges and
then cuts off the head of ileana
rasputin and so that's when valeria's
like we have to get to the galactus hive
right we have to get up there
as fast as we possibly can and so peter
leaves mary jane behind and once they
get to the to the galactus hive itself
or at least as they try to make their
escape
nana the sentinel kind of ends up giving
them a ride but nana
isn't really able to make it as fast as
she can right because she's basically
had a whole bunch of damage done to her
systems and so in her current condition
it's the fastest she can go but it's not
working because everybody's catching up
to them
right all these people are traveling as
fast as they possibly can to seize
everybody here and so what ends up
happening
is nana actually discharges her arms and
sends the rest of them flying into
galactus hive and then she's ultimately
destroyed now once they get there the
big question to ask here is
what do they do now that they're in the
galactus hive what do they do in this
situation
is it simple is it more difficult like
how does all this work and so what we
end up getting
is is valeria basically saying like i
need two minutes and that's when the
silver surfer intervenes and it makes
perfect sense that he would that the
silver surfer you know as a former
herald of galactus would basically
remain
inside of galactus right would just kind
of stay there as a kind of safety
safety device and you get this amazing
moment between
franklin richards and the surfer right
the franklin literally uses his warlock
abilities and just sends us like pins a
surfer against the wall and when the
server calls his board he takes the
sword of magic of iliana rasputin the
soul sword
and cuts the board in half right and
then just loses it just says like you
guys killed
everybody you killed forge you killed
uncle ben you killed uncle johnny you
killed nana you killed everyone and
franklin takes the full
totality of the soul sword and slices
silver surfer in half
and basically kills it now one thing to
understand here and i think it's kind of
smart that marvel did this this is not
the full totality of franklin's powers
right he doesn't really have his reality
warping abilities anymore because
seemingly his abilities were tied to his
body now in all
truth it shouldn't work that way unless
you have something like a healing factor
or something along those lines your
powers are not tied to your body your
powers are tied to your mind's ability
to control something
that's why that that bit is important
there it's how you know individuals like
the beyonder that has no true physical
form
can still do the kind of things that he
does right the beyonder takes on a
physical form but the beyonder is
essentially just living energy with
somebody like galactus he's the exact
same way if you saw galactus in his true
form he would just be a swirling mass of
energy in a giant purple suit and that
would be it right so franklin's ability
to to do what he can do is not tied to
his physical body so by all standards of
measurement
even having his consciousness
transformed or moved to a new body
should still mean that he can alter
reality on a universal scale but such as
it was philip kennedy the guy writing
this story kind of
went with the idea that franklin's
ability to utilize his powers are tied
to his physical form right and so that's
why he's not really able to use reality
warping on a massive scale at least not
that we've seen
now the other part of this of hilarious
plan that what she's doing here
is she's basically using the power of
gambit and that this hand that she has
in her possession was taken by
taken by remy lebeau taken by gambit by
forge himself and that forge would use
it as a kind of source of energy what
she's doing here is literally channeling
the power of gambit
into the heart of galactus and the
intention is to completely and totally
destroy it and so valeria tells franklin
get everybody out of here as fast as you
can right the sword
will know what to do the sword will know
how to get them away and so what it ends
up doing is whisking away franklin blade
the cat wolf reign
you know everybody here right everybody
who's here spider-man valeria herself
they all get teleported away
just as galactus entire physical form is
destroyed by uh by the hand
of of gambit now here's the funny thing
about this is that technically speaking
gambit could do this gambit could kill
galactus and the reason why
is because gambit's ability is to
basically charge up potential energy to
take potential energy turn it into
kinetic energy to basically take objects
that are in rest and put them in motion
exceedingly fast and to force them to
spontaneously combust
there are some limitations depending on
on what we're talking about here but
we're also talking about this particular
universe so we don't really know
if gambit in this universe underwent the
same kind of lobotomy process
that he did in the main marvel universe
which reduced his powers
the fact that he's powerful enough to
destroy galactus would seem
that that's not the case that he
actually never underwent that process
and there's no limit to the power that
he has the other part of this though is
that gambit's limit in terms of his
ability to destroy objects
is truly limited by his mind because of
the fact that his mind was altered to
restrict how much of his power he could
use
and so if you have a person who can
utilize the power of gambit without any
of the blocks that gambit has in his
mind then seemingly they could destroy
galactus right there's as many questions
being left unanswered here as there are
questions
being answered here but galactus in the
entire hive are completely and totally
destroyed
right so in effect the heroes basically
won here and so what we end up doing is
picking up a month later with nana being
rebuilt by the
combined efforts of valeria alongside
vivian right the daughter of vision and
with uh with blade actually training
franklin on how to use a sword
the question kind of comes down to what
comes next and what wolverine talks
about is actually
reopening the xavier school right
reopening the school and because there's
still mutants out there even though
they're in hiding
there's still mutants out there that
still have their powers and the x-men
still need to exist
so it's kind of reforming the team even
if only helping to combat whatever
forces happen to exist out there because
not all of humanity has been destroyed
not all of humanity has been defeated
and so while there are still mutant
survivors there are still human
survivors so there's still
room there to create stories of like you
know mutants against humans and
different things like that but franklin
ultimately ends up leaving right
ultimately ends up you know going back
inside the house
and heading back into his room and what
we end up finding out here is that he
still has the head of silver surfer
because he has
questions that he's been reading over
the books of charles xavier
specifically in relation to the brood
and he asks every single brood
hive has a queen right so if the brood
hive infected galactus and then in turn
galactus was brought to earth when he
infected the heroes then that means
there had to have been a brood queen on
earth so the question is
who's the brood queen right who's this
person that's in charge of the brood
this one individual that survived and
could repopulate and basically
recreate this entire zombie infection
yet again only
improve on where they messed up before
and the response to silver surfer
is that she knows exactly who you are
she knows who you are she knows what it
is that all of you guys did on this
earth and the two of you will meet soon
enough and so the indication here is
that the brood queen
is actually carol danvers right the shoe
is infected and she's the one that's
basically kind of running the show so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end
if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and let me know what you guys thought
about marvel zombies down in the
comments section if i'm being honest
with you guys
it's a much lackluster story than the
original marvel zombies it's
not nearly as good but uh yeah we're
gonna bring this to an end
and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
foreign